3億円
こんにちははじめしゃちょーでございます
というわけで今回もやってまいりました
はじめしゃちょーの3億円の豪邸最新情報
のコーナーでございますはいなんか
カタカタ言ってますけれども今日ですね
3億円のお家
さらに進化しましてちょっとねまだ作り
途中なんですけれども以上明日
完成で今日また途中段階なんですけれども
天気がいいのは今日だけなのでちょっと
今日撮っていますズバリ言わせていただき
ましょう
[音楽]
屋上でございますあーちょっともう見え
ちゃってますけどもここら辺とか今もなん
か電気繋いでちょっとやってもらってるん
ですけれども3億円のお家の屋上結構昔の
動画で3億円のうちの屋上上がったんです
けれども何もなかったぞとこれは
もったいねちょっともったいないなって
いうことで屋上
改造させていただきましたそれもかなり
有効活用しておりますのでちょっと今日は
そんな屋上見に行きたいと思いますはい
なんか電力が必要らしくてずっとね電気を
ここから送ってるみたいです行き方なん
ですけども裏からいきますとなんかねここ
1週間ぐらいすごいの世の中がもう超車
だらけ業者さんがとても頑張ってくれて
ますがなんと今家の裏こんな感じになって
ますもう足場ですよ足場屋上の行き方がね
結局なくてもう外にこうやって
階段仮説で作って登るのが一番手っ取り早
いっていうことで仮説の階段作ってもらっ
てますここから屋上に一気に行けるって
感じなので今のところ唯一あるルートこれ
ですじゃあちょっと屋上行ってきます
ちょっと待って待って待って待ってよ
めっちゃ高いぞ
行ってきます
[音楽]
高い方無理なんすよビジネスじゃない方で
行くね
もう行くよ俺
[音楽]
これマジかマジかこれ
マジかー
[音楽]
やばいちょっと待って本当にごめんなさい
ちょっと待って無理かもしれないやばい
ちょっと待って
あ
これこれまずいかも戻ってくること考え
たら結構普通に無理だやばい
やばい
スマホ持ちながらっていうのがやばい普通
だったらもうちょっと安心なんですけどね
持ちながら良くないでしょうねこれ
ちょっと頑張ります
俺んちだもん足元映してあげる
これね結構ねー
高いとこ苦手な人はもう無理ですね
[音楽]
結構すごいよ
よし
[音楽]
着きました
マジで高いところに本当に結構冗談抜きで
はいというわけで屋上なんですけれども
どのように3億円のうちの屋上改造したの
か昔の屋上見たことありますでしょうか
何にもなかったんですよ真っ白のまっさら
な屋上もったいないということでどのよう
に改造したのかご覧いただきましょう
こんな
感じです
[音楽]
怖い
はいソーラーパネルとベランダですはい
あのご覧の通りまず大量のソーラーパネル
設置しましたそしてこっちのねこれ屋上に
ですねベランダ作らせてもらいました
ソーラーパネルはわかるけどこっちのね
ベランダ結構すごいと思うのよはいそうな
んですソーラーパネルとベランダ作らせて
もらいましたソーラーパネルはねなんと
なくわかると思います発電するんです電気
を
太陽でサウナ作ったと思うんですけれども
ちょっとエコなサウナを作りたくて基本的
にサウナの電力をこのソーラーパネルで
補おうかなと思っています
環境に良いサメだってかっこよくないです
かもうね俺ぐらいになってくるとただ
サウナに入るだけじゃなく地球のことも
考えちゃうエコなサウナに入りたいので
環境によくサウナ入りたいなと思って
サウナの熱ってすごい電気が必要だから
そうならパネルでこう電気を起こそうって
いう感じで大量のソーラーパネル設置し
ました主にサウナ用なので他にも電力
使えるかなと思ってますそしてこっちです
よ皆さん
ええオーシャンビューの屋上になんだこれ
オーシャンビューの屋上にベランダ
夢だね
失礼します
熱い8時初めてだなちょっと失礼します
[拍手]
はいベランダ来ました皆さん
昔屋上に来た時俺ちらっと言ったよな
もったいないな何か置けって言われてる
ような広さちょっとね周りに柵とかつけれ
ばそうねすごい広いところだから全然また
改造の余地があると思うのでここも何かの
スペースにしたいですねそうですね
屋上にベランダ作りました
めっちゃ良くない
めっちゃ良くないですか海よここ海海見
ながらここでさなんか
椅子とか机とか持ってきて夜風を楽しみ
ながらビールとか飲んだりしちゃうことが
できたんですよこれ
誰と海沿いのこのベランダまじ最強だと
思うんですよ個人的にまだ塗りたてなん
ですよまだ塗装途中なんですけどもこれ
まだしっかり塗られてないので多分今後
塗られていきますで雨の日とかはもうここ
とかなのかな
はい
屋根付きです雨降ってもここでさあ
ちっちゃい石とか置いてさこうやってなん
か3人とか4人とかでパーティーができる
わけですよ海を楽しみながらはいという
感じの屋上になりました
海最高マジで海最高海岸沿い見ながらここ
でこうやって酒飲めるんですよタバコ吸っ
てたただこういう柵がないと本当に
危なかったのでこれはもうねつけて良かっ
たなと思ってますで問題はですよ問題は
どうやってここまで上がってくるかです
さっき来たらあそこ見たでしょあのー足場
さっき見たら足場の階段しか今ないんです
けども今ですねなんと絶賛ここに
階段つけて4階から一発で上がれるように
しようと思ってるのでここは多分ねもう
明日か明後日ぐらいに完成する予定で
ございます明日明後日には完成してる予定
だったんですけどもちょっと天気が悪い
ぽかったのにちょっと今日のうちにとっ
とこうかなと思って撮ってますはいという
わけで3億円は曇ってきたなずっと明日
天気悪いもん今日取ってよかったという
わけで3億円のうちの屋上にですね
ベランダ新しいスペースができました
なんか動画でも普通に使えそうなのでまた
機会があったらちょっと使いたいと思い
ます
ちなみにカラオケのうち引っ越してから
たくさん改造しましたサウナを作ったり
なんか電気を全部変えたり屋上にソーラー
パネル置いたりベランダ作ったり様々な
ことをしてきました今回のこの改造をもち
ましてこのお家さん家のうち確実に4億円
超えました
[音楽]